Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 258. Radio aus der Krise könnte man es nennen. Wir machen das heute ausnahmsweise nicht im Berliner Chaos Computer Club, sondern wir machen alles schön Stay at Home und reden auch darüber, was uns sowieso alle beschäftigt, nämlich wie man in den Zeiten von Stay at Home digitale Infrastruktur nutzen kann, um Dinge möglich zu machen, die jetzt eben genau deswegen nicht mehr gehen. Wir reden also darüber, wie der Club oder auch wie die Clubs leben können, wenn man ja keinen Fußball vor die Tür setzen darf. Also nicht gar keinen, aber zumindest nicht so, dass man als Menschen zusammenkommt und zum Beispiel feiert. Das ist auch genau unser erstes Thema. Wir werden vier insgesamt haben heute in der Sendung. Wir sprechen jetzt mit Lutz Leichsenring von United We Stream. Hallo und guten Abend. Wir sprechen heute zuerst mal über das Problem, dass Feiern schwierig geworden ist, weil Menschenansammlungen verboten sind. Das trifft natürlich dann auch die Orte, wo gefeiert wird oder wo getanzt wird, nämlich die Clubs. Da habt ihr euch überlegt, na ja, das kann man auch irgendwie anders machen.
Wie denn?
Wir haben einen großen Zip-Trunk bekommen, also eine... Halt, was ist ein großer Zip-Trunk? Das ist Voice-over-IP. Das ist quasi eine Telefonnummer, wo ganz, ganz viele Leute gleichzeitig anrufen können. Die geht nicht so als klassische Leitung irgendwie in ein Haus rein, sondern das ist halt so internetbasiert mit Netzwerk hintendran. Das kann man dann beliebig irgendwo hin konfigurieren auf einen Server. Den Server haben wir dann vom CCC bekommen dafür. Und diese, wie gesagt, diese 200 gleichzeitig Leitungen, die man anrufen kann, die wurden gesponsert, soweit ich das weiß. Und dann haben wir uns daran gemacht, zu überlegen, was macht man am sinnvollsten für diese Hotline? Boris hatte auch irgendwie in seinem Team schon rum überlegt, was macht man so? Gibt man ihnen ein Auswahlmenü? Und dann haben wir kurz, das war an einem, ich gucke jetzt nochmal gerade nach, es war vorletzte Woche Sonntag. Am 15.3. kam dieser Hilferuf zu uns, hier, ihr müsst uns irgendwie helfen. Wir haben hier so eine Nummer und wir haben aber keine Ahnung, wie wir da jetzt sinnvoll eine Hotline hinten dran kriegen. Und außerdem müssen wir mit den Daten die Schnittstelle von nebenan.de befüllen. Und da haben wir gesagt, naja, das können wir bestimmt irgendwie stemmen, haben uns kurz zusammengefunden, also virtuell zusammengefunden. Und dann innerhalb von tatsächlich 42 Minuten, wir haben dann geguckt, irgendwie als der erste Anruf funktionierte, haben wir innerhalb von 42 Minuten einen kompletten Server, die ganze Infrastruktur aufgesetzt. Einer hat einen Mail-Server konfiguriert, der nächste hat das Monitoring eingebaut, der nächste hat Backup auf der Kiste installiert. Die Skripte wurden geschrieben, dass die Telefonanlage, die auf diesem Server läuft, die wurde konfiguriert. Und das haben wir irgendwie alles so mehr oder weniger in 40 bis 42 Minuten so hinbekommen. Und dann gab es den ersten Anruf. Ja, wir waren selber überrascht, aber wir haben gedacht, okay, jetzt können wir anrufen, wie lange haben wir den jetzt gebraucht? Wie lange ist denn diese virtuelle Maschine jetzt schon an? Und ich weiß nicht, die 42 ist ja in den Kreisen auch recht bekannt und es waren tatsächlich wirklich 42 Minuten.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, normalerweise installiert man irgendwas und denkt, naja gut, das wird nicht sofort funktionieren. In diesem Fall hat es das getan.
Es hat das fast sofort getan. Wir haben natürlich noch über die Tage danach immer wieder noch Änderungen gemacht. Der Text wurde drei- viermal umgeworfen. Ich habe dann angeboten, weil ich auch ein Studio habe, dass ich den Text einspreche dafür. Der wurde dann zwei- dreimal neu gemacht. Und dann mussten noch Rechtsanwälte drüber gucken. Und dann musste das noch irgendwie überlegt werden, wie diese Datenübergabe nach nebenan.de funktioniert. Aber letztendlich haben wir das dann alles zusammenbekommen. Und der aktuelle Ablauf sieht jetzt so aus, man ruft diese Rufnummer an. Kann man auch auf gemeinschaft.online die Rufnummer sehen. Da ist auch nochmal ein bisschen erklärt, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Dann ruft man da an, man bekommt ein Auswahlmenü, gibt seine Postleitzahl ein. Das ist relativ wichtig, damit nebenan.de diese Hilfegesuche auch in die entsprechenden Bereiche schieben kann, wo Leute helfen wollen.
Ich habe das schon ein paar Mal gehört, aber weiß nicht ganz genau.
Nebenan.de ist so ein großes Nachbarschaftsnetzwerk, wo man sich registrieren kann und kann in seiner lokalen Umgebung Leute um Hilfe bitten oder kann den Leuten Sachen anbieten. Ich brauche eine Bohrmaschine in Kreuzberg oder so. Oder ich brauche was auch immer, jemanden, der mir im Garten hilft oder der eine Hecke schneiden kann. Dann können die Nachbarn aus dem direkten Umland diese Gesuche sehen und darauf antworten. Das ist ja für Leute, die Internet haben, überhaupt kein Problem. Allerdings in der zu erwartenden Notlage, wenn dann wirklich ältere Menschen Hilfe brauchen, die brauchen Leute, die für sie einkaufen, dann haben die jetzt die Möglichkeit, einfach diese Rufnummer anzurufen. Die tippen ihre Postleitzahl ein und dann können sie aus vier Kategorien auswählen, wo sie Hilfe bei benötigen. Ob beim Einkaufen oder bei Hunden oder Tieren im Allgemeinen. Ob sie irgendwas repariert haben möchten oder dann gibt es auch noch den Punkt Sonstiges. Und dann haben wir zusätzlich noch eine Partnerschaft mit dieser Rufnummer mit dem Silbernetz e.V. Das ist eine Gruppe von freiwilligen, von ehrenamtlichen Menschen, die tagsüber am Telefon sitzen und Anrufe entgegennehmen. Und mit denen kann man einfach mal quatschen, wenn man mit denen reden möchte. Das heißt, gegen Altersarm, Einsamkeit oder sowas hilft das. Und das wird auch sehr gut angenommen. Wir haben uns gedacht, wenn wir keine Rückrufnummer haben von den Leuten, die anrufen, von den älteren Menschen, dann müssen wir denen ja trotzdem irgendwie helfen. Und deswegen werden die dann z.B. zu Silbernetz durchgestellt. Da sitzen dann Menschen und die können dann im Zweifelsfall diese Informationen entgegennehmen.
Warte mal, man ruft da an und dann klickt man sich sozusagen durch, was man will?
Ganz genau.
Gibt seine Postleitzahl ein und kriegt dann genau was zurück.
Dann bekommt man die Info, dass die Anfrage weitergeleitet wird an nebenan.de. Und da wird die dann als Hilfegesuch eingestellt. Und wenn man auf nebenan.de sagt, ich möchte dieser Person helfen, also man sieht das halt nur, wenn man auch in der Region wohnt.
Warte, das wird eingestellt. Was heißt das? Das wird sozusagen aus diesem, er hat Taste 1 für Einkaufen gedrückt und die Postleitzahl ist 18397. Daraus wurde ein automatischer Textbaustein generiert und als Anzeige ausgelöst.
Ganz genau, das ist so eine Hilfe-Gesuch-Anzeige. Da steht dann drin, in deinem Postleitzahlenbereich 1-5 braucht jemand Hilfe beim Einkaufen. Und als nebenan.de Mitglied kann man dann sagen, der Person möchte ich helfen. Und dann bekommt man eine E-Mail mit der Telefonnummer von der Person. Und dann kann man die anrufen und dann kann man fragen, ja, wie sieht genau die Hilfe aus? Was kann ich tun? Was wird benötigt? Und dann wird der Person geholfen. Stand heute haben wir 378 Anrufe bisher vermittelt. Und davon sind 190 Richtung Silbernetz abgebogen. Die wollten halt mit jemandem Echten sprechen.
Und gibt es auch schon Erkenntnisse, wie das dann funktioniert? Also wie das funktioniert hat, ob da Hilfe zustande gekommen ist?
Das haben wir bisher noch keinen Feedback bekommen. Das wird man wahrscheinlich mal so in ein, zwei Tagen nochmal gucken können, wenn da noch ein bisschen mehr drauf geht. Also die Last ist jetzt noch nicht allzu hoch. Das ist ja auch ein gutes Zeichen. Wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt über den Zeitraum von anderthalb Wochen ungefähr 380 Anrufe bekommen, wo Leute im Menü irgendwie was ausgewählt haben. Und viel mehr sehen wir auch nicht. Wir schieben dann, sobald dieser Anruf fertig ist, geben wir diese Informationen halt weiter an nebenan.de und die verarbeiten diese Daten dann. Und machen daraus die Anzeigen. Wir haben also nur einen kleinen, einen klitzekleinen Teil davon gebaut. Da sind ja noch viel, viel mehr Leute drum herum beteiligt. Es gibt irgendwie Leute, die die Webseite dafür gemacht haben. Es wurde ein Fernsehwerbespot produziert dafür. Auf der Webseite? Ja, ja, es gibt einen richtigen Werbespot, wo eine von den ehrenamtlichen Mitarbeiterinnen von Silbernetz, die uns halt, da hat uns geholfen, diesen Werbespot zu machen. Es gibt ganz, ganz viele Leute, die das gemacht haben. Es gibt eine große Liste auf gemeinschaft.online. Wenn ich die jetzt alle aufzähle, das kann eh keiner behalten. Aber da gibt es eine tolle Liste, wo man sehen kann, wer uns wirklich alles geholfen hat. Und das auch in kürzester Zeit, wo wirklich viele, viele Menschen, über 100 Leute, daran gearbeitet haben, gemeinschaftlich.
Immer friedlich zusammen, Entschuldigung, dass ich das fragen muss. Aber es ist ja so, wenn technische Projekte aus dem Boden gestampft werden, mit sehr vielen Beteiligten, das ist ja manchmal auch schwierig.
Das hat eigentlich recht gut geklappt. Wir hatten am Anfang natürlich so die üblichen Kommunikationsprobleme, weil wir kannten uns noch gar nicht. Also wir kannten Boris nicht. Boris kannte uns nur vom Kongress. Und die machen da dieses Telefon. Das war so sein Eindruck, was er kannte. Aber das war, ich glaube, das war nach zwei, drei Stunden, war das Problem gegessen. Und dann waren die Sachen klar, die Anforderungen waren klar. Und dann haben wir darunter implementiert.
Cool. Hört sich gut an. Die war es das jetzt? Also quasi ist das fertig im Sinne von, ihr habt das jetzt gebaut und jetzt funktioniert das. Super gutes Ding. Oder sind noch Dinge geplant?
Also sind noch so ein paar Dinge geplant. Es gibt noch wohl Anverragen vom Roten Kreuz, glaube ich. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Es gibt auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Anfragen, die da auch Probleme mit ihren aktuellen Hotlines haben. Es gibt ja auch noch so ein paar andere Hotlines in diesem Land, die aktuell nicht so gut funktionieren. Und die sind wohl auch schon an Boris herangetreten. Und jetzt gucken wir, dass wir so die Anforderungen einsammeln, was die haben wollen. Und dann überlegen wir uns, ob wir das nochmal wieder realisieren können.
Woran scheitert das?
Ich glaube tatsächlich an den Strukturen, die nicht vorhanden sind. Also jetzt als Beispiel die Telefonnummer für die Arbeitsagentur, diese Hotline, die es da gibt. Ich glaube, die ist lokal organisiert. Und da sitzen jetzt einfach keine Leute aktuell, weil viele von denen wahrscheinlich Homeoffice machen. Also das sind jetzt alles nur Vermutungen. Aber das ist halt einfach nicht dafür ausgelegt, dass das in dieser Größenordnung skaliert, wenn auf einmal wie viele Hunderttausend Menschen jetzt Angst um ihren Job haben, weil sie in irgendeinem Restaurant arbeiten, was geschlossen ist. Oder wo auch immer sie arbeiten, was gerade nicht offen ist. Und wenn sie dann da nur nicht festangestellt sind und so, dann stehen die halt jetzt auf der Straße. Wenn die halt das Arbeitsamt anrufen wollen und da geht keiner ran über Wochen, das ist natürlich irgendwie auch nicht besonders toll. Und wenn man dann wenigstens die Möglichkeit hätte, keine Ahnung, so eine Art Ticket aufzumachen. Wie gesagt, die Ideen sind da vielfältig. Wenn wir genau wissen, was benötigt wird und wir dann in unserem Rahmen da helfen können, dann machen wir das super gerne.
Wie finanziert ihr das eigentlich? Also sammelt ihr da auch Spenden ein oder seid ihr aus der Kategorie, ich verdiene in meinem normalen IT-Job so gut, dass ich jetzt hier einfach so arbeiten kann?
Irgendwer muss es ja machen.
Aber irgendwer muss trotzdem auch essen.
Richtig, ja. Wir haben alle einen Day-Job. Wir arbeiten alle irgendwie mehr oder weniger in der IT-Branche. Deswegen geht es uns im Moment auch noch ganz okay. Weil IT kann halt eigentlich immer arbeiten, zumindest was das angeht. Aber die eigentlichen Leute bei uns, die machen das so nebenher. Es muss halt gemacht werden. Und wir haben Ahnung davon, das war jetzt für uns keine große, also als wir die Anforderungen gehört haben wir gesagt, ach so, naja gut, das kann man ja mal schnell machen. Ich habe hier etwas vorbereitet. Der Server selber, den hat der CCC dann bezahlt. Das sind irgendwie auch ein paar Euro nur im Monat. Das sind keine großen Posten. Und für sowas, was tatsächlich Menschen hilft, da muss man das einfach mal auf sich nehmen.
Sehr, sehr cool. Braucht ihr noch Hilfe? Kann man da noch irgendwas tun?
Also man kann sich bestimmt bei Boris noch melden, wenn man irgendwie mithelfen will. Es gibt ja jetzt vielleicht dann nochmal in Zukunft Projekte, wo irgendwie Dinge getan werden müssen. Ich werde auch den Tweet auf jeden Fall nochmal mit in die Show Notes packen bzw. ich schicke dir den und dann kannst du den rein machen. Da kann man mit Sicherheit nochmal Bezug drauf nehmen und dann gibt es da bestimmt auch noch wieder weitere Hilfegesuche, wenn da nochmal was benötigt wird.
Sehr schön. Cool. Die Gemeinschaftspunkt online ist die Webseite zu dem Projekt. Könnt ihr da rauf gucken. Und wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der Hilfe braucht, dem ihr nicht selber helfen könnt, dann gebt ihm diese Adresse. Vielleicht hilft das ja. Nicht schlecht. Dann bleibt gesund und viel Spaß noch.
Danke ebenfalls.
Bis dann. Tschüss. So, dann haben wir jetzt Party gemacht, Bildung gemacht, den einsamen Menschen am Telefon geholfen und reden gleich mal darüber, wie es eigentlich mit der Videoverbreitung durch das VOC, also dem Videoverbreitungszentrum des Chaos Computer Clubs, funktioniert. Vorher noch eine letzte kleine Musik von TKN, die auch von dem Album Quest kommt und in diesem Fall einfach Quest auch heißt. Das war TKN nochmal mit Quest im Chaosradio 258, wo wir jetzt noch ein letztes Thema haben bei digitale Alternativen zu Dingen, die man vor der Krise analog gemacht hat, aber jetzt nicht mehr so richtig gehen. Und da zählen auch Chaosveranstaltungen zu. Also es gibt ja nicht nur den Chaos Communication Congress, es gibt ja auch viele kleinere Dinge oder Dinge, die zu anderen Terminen passieren. Und da gab es schon immer eine Kultur von hey, lass uns doch auch live per Video übertragen. Aber jetzt ist es ja gerade so, dass diese Dinge einfach nicht stattfinden können. Und die Frage ist, was passiert jetzt und welche Rolle kann das VOC dabei spielen? Und dazu ist Danimo jetzt bei mir. Hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
So, wie findet das denn jetzt alles statt? Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist das nächste Chaos Event, also was jetzt als nächstes passiert wäre, aber nicht passiert?
Das nächste wäre das Easter Egg gewesen und danach die GPN und dann noch viele kleine andere Events und Jugendhackt und weiß ja gar nicht alles. Also unsere Liste ist lang, auch auf der Seite von VOC unter c3voc.de einzusehen übrigens. Und diese Liste ist jetzt doch ganz beträchtlich geschrumpft. Und gleichzeitig sind halt die Leute, die sonst Vorträge gehalten hätten und die Leute, die diese Veranstaltung gerne besucht hätten, alle auf die gleiche Idee gekommen, nämlich lass mal das VOC anschreiben. Ob die da nicht was steichseln können.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn ich den Anfang der Sendung nehme, also United We Stream, wir machen einfach den DJ ohne Leute, das wäre doch exakt auch dasselbe gewesen dann, oder nicht?
Genau, also die Idee liegt ja sehr nahe. Die hatten wir, die hatten also wirklich viele andere auch. Das Einzige ist, es ist für uns, so wie wir sonst arbeiten, so ein bisschen unbetretenes Territorium. Weil normalerweise sind wir halt irgendwo vor Ort und haben da irgendwie gesichert Internet und irgendwie alles ist so ein bisschen wenigstens planbar. Wenn Leute jetzt aus ihrem Wohnzimmer oder aus ihrem Arbeitszimmer oder sonst wo streamen, um sozusagen ihren Vortrag zu halten, um ihr Projekt drüber zu bringen, dann stehen wir ja vor ganz anderen Herausforderungen. Nämlich wir kennen die, wir wissen nicht, wie die Leute angebunden sind, wie zuverlässig das funktioniert. Also gerade jetzt unter den Bedingungen des Corona-Shutdowns, Netzbetreiber zittern um ihre Ressourcen, Streamingdienste reduzieren, Bandbreiten.
Warte mal, warte mal, ich möchte kurz den Ausflug machen, der Hoffnung, dass du ein bisschen informierter bist als ich. Ich habe das auch gelesen, die Schlagzeile bei Netflix macht weniger Bandbreite. Habe aber auch gelesen, das ist eigentlich Quatsch und überflüssig. Wie ist es denn jetzt wirklich? Also ich merke, ich meine zu merken, dass das Internet wackeliger ist als sonst. Das kann aber auch daran liegen, dass ich Kunde einer Firma bin, die Zahlen im Namen hat.
Also grundsätzlich erst mal nein. Es kriselt, es kriselt aber mehr, je dichter man zum Endbenutzer kommt. Weil die klassische Planung ist halt irgendwie alles klar. Wir haben irgendwie so und so viele Kunden. Wir können ungefähr planen, wann welche Auslastung ist. Und wir können halt locker mehr Kunden auf die Infrastruktur nehmen, als die Infrastruktur eigentlich abkann. Das nennt sich Oversubscription. Und das ist ja an sich erst mal kein Problem, weil man halt weiß, dass nicht jeder seine, keine Ahnung, 100 Megabit, 200 Megabit, 500 Megabit, weiß ja gar ja was, tatsächlich auch abruft. Und dann kalkulieren die das halt alle und dann wird halt auch heftig überbrucht. Und das ist so ein bisschen, wie man das von Flugzeugen vielleicht kennt. Wer fliegt oder so, da passiert es ja auch mal, dass man irgendwie nicht mitfliegen kann, weil sie gesagt haben, ihren Platz haben wir leider vergeben, weil wir gehen davon aus, dass so und so viel Prozent der Leute nicht zum Flug auftauchen.
Okay, das heißt deswegen wackelt es jetzt vielleicht manchmal?
Ja, und wegen Gegebenheiten von Übertragungstechniken. Also wir haben glaube ich mal einen großen Teil einer Chaosradio-Sendung über die Vor- und Nachteile von DSL und Kabel und solche Übertragungstechnologien packen wir in die Show Notes verbracht. Will ich hier nicht wiederholen. Also es sind einige anfälliger dafür, andere weniger, weil man sich teilweise irgendwie so ein Kabel mit mehreren hundert Leuten teilt und dann kann man sich schon vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen schwierig wird.
Okay, ihr wisst also nicht, wenn da jetzt jemand per Video einen Vortrag halten will, wie ist der angebunden? Kann man das vorher irgendwie testen? Also klar kann man sozusagen einen anecdotischen Test machen, aber kann man irgendwie sicherstellen, dass das dann auch hält, was es versprochen hat?
Nö. Naja, das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen irgendwie einem Firmenanschluss, wo jemand kommt und dir eine Faser legt und dann auch die technische Infrastruktur bereitstellt, dass diese, keine Ahnung, 200 Megabit, der eine Gigabit wirklich für dich anliegen und irgendwie...
Ja, das ist schon klar, aber es geht ja darum, was macht man dann damit, wenn man so einen Vortrag... Gibt es dann die Möglichkeit, dass man sagt, naja, pass mal auf, solange es irgendwie reicht von der Bandbreite, machen wir ein richtiges Video, stellst du eine Kamera, machst deine Webcam vielleicht an. Wenn nicht, dann kannst du vielleicht so Slides zeigen, weil dann steht das Bild still und es dann verbraucht weniger Bandbreite. Oder wie klärt ihr das dann?
Genau, also wir arbeiten jetzt an einem Konzept, das uns sozusagen so ein bisschen gegen solche Probleme feiert, was also möglichst universal einsetzbar ist, wo man also sagen kann, okay, ich traue mich hier gar nichts, ich zeichne meinen Vortrag halt auf und ihr nehmt das dann irgendwie zur gegebenen Zeit in eine Sendeschleife mit rein. Oder wie wir machen das live und wenn das wackelt, dann zeichne ich, dann wird das nochmal beim Vortragen dann aufgezeichnet. Da läuft einfach ein Recording mit und dann sehen wir ja sozusagen, was das bringt. Und das sind alles so Überlegungen, die wir gerade anstellen. Und unterm Strich müssen wir es halt ausprobieren. Wir sind da gerade noch in der sehr, sehr frühen Probierphase. Deswegen haben wir auch noch nicht so viele Ergebnisse. Aber wichtig sind halt auch so Vollüberlegungen, die wir gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel, wenn man das jetzt so kennt, also die erste Überlegung war so, lass halt irgendwie so so Jitsi nehmen oder wie sie nicht alle heißen, also so klassische Software, die man für Meetings nimmt. Und das ist halt nicht so clever, weil eigentlich will man ja nur einem zugucken. Und eigentlich braucht der auch nicht die Slides uns seine Kamera schicken, sondern der kann uns eigentlich schon ein fertiges Signal schicken. Weil dann schwarmen wir nochmal Bandbreite. Das ist halt alles zu Überlegungen.
Ist das nicht schon eine große Herausforderung, dass man der Vortragende dann nicht nur Vortrag halten muss, sondern auch noch Bildregie führen soll?
Das wollen wir halt eben so weit wie möglich abnehmen. Also dadurch, dass wir quasi fertige Konfix abliefern, dass wir sagen, alles klar, wir sagen dir genau, wie du dich vorbereiten kannst, wie du mit bestehenden Mitteln erst mal ein möglichst gutes Bild hinkriegst und möglichst wenig Probleme bekommst. Das nimmt dir schon mal Stress. Und indem wir sagen, wenn du dich auf deinen Vortrag konzentrieren willst, dann nimmst du diese Einstellung, drückst auf Stream und dann hältst du deinen Vortrag. Und um alles andere kümmern wir uns.
Du hast ja, ihr liefert dem eine Software an oder der?
Genau, das ist, wir arbeiten im Moment oder wir experimentieren im Moment mit OBS, das ist ja so das, was in der Streaming-Szene so klassischerweise viele Leute hernehmen. Und da kann man Presets quasi einstellen. Und dieses Preset kann man einfach an die Vortragenden verschicken.
Also OBS ist eine Software, wo man Bildquellen reinwerfen kann. Also man kann seine Spielkonsole an eine HDMI-Hardware anschließen, die das als Signal übersetzt. Oder man kann sagen Webcam und die Software kann auch von alleine Bild in Bild. Also man kann sagen hier, das ist die eine Bildquelle, das ist die andere Bildquelle. Okay, ich verstehe. Ihr liefert nicht die Software, ihr sagt, ladet die Software runter. Dann gibt es von euch sozusagen eine Konfigurationsdatei. Und wenn man das beides zusammen ausgeführt hat, dann kann man im Prinzip wenig falsch machen.
Das ist so die Idee an der ganzen Geschichte. Genau, also wie gesagt, die Validierung steht noch aus. Aber das, was wir bisher damit probiert haben, so für uns, sieht erst mal ganz gut aus. Man erreicht damit auch eine Qualität, die dort sehr akzeptabel ist.
Ich muss trotzdem noch Sachen fragen. Vielleicht sagst du dann, nein, das wissen wir noch nicht. Aber ich glaube, das sind trotzdem Probleme, die man sprechen sollte. Das eine ist, das ist ja dann immer ein Vortrag. Aber das Schöne an einer Veranstaltung ist ja, dass die eine Dramaturgie hat im Zweifelsfall. Also gibt es dann noch eine weitere Videozuspielquelle, wo jemand das moderiert. Und wer sorgt denn dafür, dass diese Videos auch nahtlos ineinander in der gehen? Also habt ihr sozusagen so eine Art War Room, wo ihr dann sitzt und Regler umlegt?
Naja, das mit dem War Room scheitert ja schon daran. Ein War Room möchte ja gerne von mehreren Leuten bespielt werden.
Ha, schwierig. Im Internet, im Internet.
Im Internet, Marcus, dass du es ansprichst. Also in diesem Internet installieren wir also eine virtuelle Maschine, auf der noch mal eine, bis jetzt gehen wir davon aus, dass wir da auch OBS für nehmen werden, also noch eine OBS-Instance laufen wird, die wiederum diese ganzen Streams annehmen wird. Und die funktioniert so ein bisschen wie so eine zentrale Senderabwicklung bei einem klassischen Fernsehsender. Das heißt, dort laufen die ganzen Signale auf und wenn eine Vortragende fertig ist, können wir auf den anderen übergehen oder wir geben eine Pausenschleife drauf oder wir geben einen Herald drauf, der solange bis der nächste Vortragende am Start ist, ein bisschen gute Laune verbreitet und ein paar Infos verteilt. Also das sind alles so Ideen, mit denen wir spielen, was natürlich auch so ein bisschen eine Herausforderung ist, weil du kennst es ja wahrscheinlich auch aus deinem Tagesjob. Du musst irgendwie vorher mit den Leuten reden können. Du musst sie vorbereiten, dass sie gleich dran sind. Du musst irgendwie eine Art Übergabe hinkriegen.
Was mich vor allem die Frage ist, das ist ja bei Audio schon kompliziert genug, aber Audio hat den Vorteil, dass es so schmal ist vom Datenverbrauch, dass es relativ instantan ist. Wenn ich mich an meine Versuche erinnere, per eben dieser OBS-Software Videospiel-Dinge zu streamen, dann ist der Lack, bevor das auf der Webseite ankommt, so 30 Sekunden bis eine Minute. Das heißt, wenn ich Chat-Nachrichten lese, beziehen sie sich auf etwas, was in meiner Welt schon eine Minute vorbei ist. Das macht auch ein ganz großes Problem bei solchen Übergängen. Wenn ich jetzt der nächste Vortragende bin, dann muss ich ja schon eine Minute angefangen haben, bevor der Moderator, der mich ankündigt, fertig ist. Das heißt, gibt es Mittel für Kommunikation? Wie gibt man jemanden das Signal, jetzt musst du loslegen?
Ja, also da gibt es mehrere Strategien. Also ich will erst mal darauf eingehen, warum das überhaupt eine Minute bei dir dauert. Und zwar das Ganze läuft nochmal bei deinem Streaming-Anbieter durch so eine Kaskade von Servern. Das dauert einfach ein bisschen. Und außerdem funktioniert die Art und Weise, wie das ausgespielt wird, so dass du viele kleine Schnipsel hast, viele kleine Videoschnipsel. Die wird dann in so einer Art Playliste ausgeliefert. Da gibt es zwei Standards. Der eine heißt HLS, das ist das, was Apple macht. Der andere heißt Dash. Das ist das, was alle anderen machen. Aber die setzen halt voraus, dass du erstmal so ein paar Schnipsel... Dass du erstmal so ein paar Schnipsel...
Für mein Verständnis. Das heißt, das anderthalbstündige Streaming-Video von Diablo, das ich rausgeschickt habe, ist gar kein anderthalbstündiges Video im Livestream, sondern im Prinzip eine Ansammlung von kurzen Videos, die aber nacheinander so ausgeliefert werden, dass es für mich wie ein langes Video aussieht?
Genau, das macht dein Player. Und der Vorteil daran ist, dein Player kann darauf reagieren, dass zum Beispiel die Bandbreite knapp wird und der Server liefert dir nicht nur verschiedene Schnipsel aus, sondern sagt auch, pass mal auf, wenn gerade die Bandbreite ein bisschen dünn ist, dann nimm doch diese Datei statt der Datei und die ist dann vielleicht nicht mehr Full HD und sieht auch ein bisschen matcher aus, aber dafür bleibst du wenigstens am Spiel und am Zeitrand ohne, dass dieser berühmte Buffering kommt. Genau, aber das ist eines der Gründe, das ist nicht unbedingt der zentrale Grund, aber das ist mit eines der Gründe, weswegen du immer so eine Verzögerung hast. Und da derjenige, der das dann an uns schickt, quasi das nicht über dieses Verfahren macht, sagen wir mal, hast du vielleicht eine Sekundelatenz, zwei. Aber klar, der Rückkanal, der irgendwie ihm sagt, pass auf, jetzt kann es losgehen, das müssen wir anders realisieren. Da wird er wahrscheinlich ein Knopf ins Ohr kriegen. Also nimmt sich irgendwie sein Headset und da läuft dann ein Mumble drauf. Also das sind so Ideen, die wir im Moment haben. Oder ganz banal Text, Chat, IRC, das ist ja quasi auch instantan.
Was das Schöne an Chaos veranstaltet ist, ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht auf so vielen außer auf dem Kongress, tut mir leid. Aber beim Kongress ist ja was ganz Krasses und auch Selbstorganisiertes, dass viele Vorträge auch noch simultan übersetzt werden.
Ja, da haben sich auch die Übersetzer schon gemeldet, also das Translation Team und da arbeiten wir auch noch an Lösungen. Also das ist vorsichtig geplant. Ich kann da noch nichts genaues sagen, weil ich mich in den Planungen tatsächlich noch nicht rein gefuchst habe. Im Zweifelsfall wird es wieder sowas geben wie ein Mumble, wo man sich zusätzlich reinklinken kann, so wie das in den Vortrags-Sellen war. Wenn es richtig gut läuft, kriegen wir es vielleicht auch hin, das mit dem ganz normalen Stream auszuliefern. Aber wenn dann die Verzögerung so doof wird, dass man quasi den Kontext gar nicht mitbekommt, weil da irgendwie mehrere Sekunden dazwischen sind, also mehr als man es jetzt hätte, wenn man das klassisch auf dem Kongress hat, dann dauert es ja auch mal ein bisschen, bis der Simultanübersetzer dann wirklich hinterherkommt. Und wenn dann noch mal zusätzlich Verzögerung raufkommt, dann ist es das irgendwann nicht mehr wert. Und dann muss man sich halt überlegen, dass man zumindest für das Livestreaming an sich erst mal, das dann vielleicht noch auf einer anderen Technik macht. Aber wie gesagt, da arbeiten wir noch dran. Und es ist auf jeden Fall auf unserem Radar.
So, das hört sich jetzt alles ein bisschen nach an. Es gibt die schönen Ideen. Aber wann können wir denn das vielleicht zum ersten Mal beobachten?
Du erinnerst dich, dass ich sagte, zum Beispiel ist das Easter Hack ausgefallen und anstelle aller die Zuhören und sich interessieren für ein Online-Event, das so, wie ich das gerade beschrieben habe, eventuell stattfinden könnte, die sollten sich Ostern mal vielleicht nichts vornehmen.
Okay, braucht man denn noch Hilfe?
Im Moment basteln wir selber erst mal so vor uns hin mit den bestehenden Leuten, weil es einfach gerade eine Frage von Zeit ist. Ich bewundere Sascha immer wieder und überhaupt die ganze Eventphone-Crew, wie sie sozusagen Zeit finden. Ich habe halt auch noch einen Tagesjob, das geht anderen auch so. Aber je näher dann quasi die gesetzte Deadline kommt, umso schneller gehen dann auch klassischerweise Dinge. Es ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn Leute kommen und ihre Hilfe anbieten, dann finden wir das grundsätzlich immer ganz klasse. Das Problem ist immer so ein bisschen, wir arbeiten ein bisschen wie Broadcast-Leute, wir arbeiten ein bisschen wie ITler. Aber meistens kommen die Leute entweder von der einen oder von der anderen Seite und müssen sich das andere quasi erst angucken. Das ist in der konkreten Situation. Wir laufen auf ein Event so immer schwierig. Deswegen generell sind wir immer total dafür, dass sich Leute sozusagen unsere Technik angucken und uns auch helfen oder Teil des VOCs werden. Aber idealerweise nie im näheren Zulauf auf ein Event, weil das wird dann immer schwierig und das ist dann auch immer doof, die Leute zu enttäuschen, weil sie dann möglicherweise nicht das tun können, was sie sich erhofft haben, dass sie tun können.
Das hört sich so ein bisschen an nach wie rufen sie uns nicht an, wie rufen sie an.
Nee, im Gegenteil, also klassischerweise würde ich immer sagen, kommt zu kleineren Events. Das ist hier halt ein bisschen schwierig gerade. Also klassischerweise lesen wir Leute immer oder schicken wir Leute immer gezielt zu kleineren Events, weil wir dann auch wirklich Zeit haben, uns darum zu kümmern. Hier würde ich sagen analog, wenn wir das erste Event geflogen haben, dann ist es optimal. Was nicht heißt, dass Leute uns nicht schreiben können und nicht sich anbieten können. Also wir haben auch eine Mailing-Liste, video.list.ccc.de, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Fragen, Hilfe anbieten, schadet nie. Es geht nur so ein bisschen darum, dann quasi die große Enttäuschung da direkt rauszunehmen.
Na gut, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das wird.
Ich auch.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage. Das Chaosradio ist in den letzten Sendungen immer mit Bild gewesen. Das ist ja heute nicht so. Darin auch gearbeitet.
Selbes Problem, würde ich sagen, also selbes Problem. Schauen wir mal. Ich wäre sehr dafür, wenn wir das Problem nicht mehr hätten, bis so zeitnah. Aber ich fürchte, das wird uns noch ein bisschen erhalten bleiben. Und insofern, wir arbeiten dran.
Alles klar, das machen wir. Sehr schön, dann Danimo, vielen Dank. Wir sind gespannt, was da noch kommen wird. Und auch dir bleibt gesund und bis bald. So, das war dann schon das Chaos Radio 258 gesendet aus den Stay-At-Home-Studios. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich habe versucht, durch die Sendung zu führen. Falls ihr noch ein tolles Projekt habt, das ihr jetzt kennengelernt habt, wo ihr sagt, hey, das ist auch super, das ist auch eine digitale Alternative zum analogen Leben, das uns gerade verwehrt bleibt, schreibt es uns in die Kommentare oder schreibt es uns an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und dann können wir es vielleicht noch mal irgendwo unterbringen. Mal schauen, wie lange uns das jetzt noch sozusagen weiter ereilt, auch wenn das gemein klingt. Ich hoffe ja, die Arbeit, die sich das VOC zum Beispiel macht, ist umsonst. Ich glaube es nicht, aber schön wäre es eigentlich schon. Gut, damit entlassen wir euch jetzt in den nächsten Monaten, dann hören wir uns wieder. Wir haben noch eine letzte Musik und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.